vielen lieben Dank vielen
dank vielen Dank danke schön ihr werdet noch so
viel klatschen müssen heute ihr würdet noch so
viel klatschen nein ich korrigere mich ihr
werdet noch so viel klatschen wollen heute
übertreibt nicht direkt am Anfang spart euch auf
wir ich ich kühle euch direkt ein bisschen runter
AFD super hoch in den Umfragen ja das ist aber
ich kann es ja muss man ich find es gar nicht
so negativ ich kann es verstehen muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen es ist ne wegen der Inflation ne
und dann war der Sommer nicht so gut was willst
du da machen da musst du Nazis wählen eigentlich
das geht eigentlich gar nichtchuldigung das war
das war wo ist die Kamera da das war pauschal
mit den Nazis jetzt das war das muss ich richtig
stellen das sind Neonazis ne das muss man schon
sagen das sind ja nicht die von früher ne also
bis auf gauland ich glaube der der ist noch über
nein möchte ich noch mal sagen es mir ganz wichtig
das sind nicht alles Nazis das habe ich mir extra
aufgeschrieben weil ich vergesse auch so oft ja
also es sind nicht alle Nazis bei der AFD das
ne ich fühle mich besser das sind
drei Prozesse weniger das muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen ach das G nee das ist
ja die sagen das ja auch selber dass sie
gar nicht gar keine Nazis sind gar nicht ne aber
mal angenommen nur mal angenommen ne du wärst na
bei der AFD also warum auch immer komme der
Teufel drauf warum ja dann würde ich mich auch
distanzieren als Nazi das würde ich auch sagen da
wür ich auch sagen ich bin kein Nazi schon sagen
weil das ist ja die haben ja gerade Image Problem
Faschismus hat ein Image Problem muss man schon
sagen das ist ja immer noch oder das ist wirklich
wenn man da so ein Geschichtsbuch aufmacht das ist
ja Testurteil ungenügend das ist ja auch gar nicht
gut fürs tinderprofil nazisuche Anschluss erst
nicht an Österreich das geht nicht das die AFD tut
ja auch so also also viele in der AFD tun schon
so als wäre das so früher so eine so eine wie so
eine spannende achterbadenfahrt gewesen ne also
und wenn man jetzt den schieenvergleich nimmt da
muss man schon sagen also faschismus ist wie eine
Achterbahn die man ein schweren Unfall hatte ne
ja und dann und so dann musst du dich natürlich
erstmal distanzieren dann musst du sagen also
da wollen wir uns maximal von der Achterbahn von
damals distanzieren ja das ist das war furchtbar
war dass da 58 Menschen gestorben sind ne das war
wirklich also da mit dieser acht mit diesem
Looping ins Nichts das war keine gute Idee da
distanzieren wir uns ne deswegen haben wir das ja
jetzt auch noch mal neu angestrichen in blau ne
weil das so braun durchgerostet war nein einfach
nur dass man es hat wir wollen die ja nicht
eröffnen wir wollen die nicht eröffnen das ist ja
quatsch das wollen wir nicht nee geht uns einfach
um die achterbahnkultur in Deutschland dass die
erhalten bleibt nein das war furchtbar mit dem
Unfall ja da gibt's nichts klein zu reden aber man
kann jetzt die Achterbahn nicht nur auf den Unfall
reduzieren ne das war ja auch das war vorher
waren das ja richtig haben die Leute richtig
Spaß gehabt da auf der Achterbahn ne die war ja
12 Jahre lang unfallfrei ne also Millionen von
glücklichen Stunden im Vergleich dann zu ein paar
Schrecksekunden ne das ist ja ein Fliegenschiss
der Geschichte muss man schon sagen bitte das ist
jetzt schon das war jetzt zu viel wieder oder was
das war schon zu nechuldigung möchte ich mich auch
direkt wieder distanzieren da distanziere ich mich
von der distanzi wie auch immer ihr mögt das ist
für mich gar kein Problem nein da muss ich sagen
da das geht gar nicht um Hass ne falls hier Leute
denken es geht um Hass es geht also vielleicht
liebe ich zu sehr die achterbahnkultur ne das das
kann sein das ist ja dass man zu sehr liebt das
gibt's ja auch ne wenn man dann jemanden umarmt
und dann zu doll umarmt so vielleicht ja nee nein
das war schrecklich mit den 28 Menschen die da
gestorben H was 58 ja da streiten sich ja die
Gelehrten ne also das muss man nee und muss man
auch mal Fragen waren das alles gute Menschen die
da ach das ist jetzt das ist jetzt auch wieder
wirklich da will man einmal Achterbahnfahren
das ist jetzt auch schon wieder Rassismus
oder was das finde ich rassistisch von
euch ne dass ihr das überhaupt denkt finde
ich schwierig gerade die Situation hier ne
fine ich so ja Richtung Meinungsfreiheit
das seid ja ihr ich bin ja ich finde das
nazimäßig von euch dass ihr denkt dass
ich ein Nazi bin ja also richtig fixiert
finde ich das das ist ja schlecht ja das
ist ja das ist ja ihr schützt die waren
Nazis nein wir sind ich ich würde da
auch Leute aus fremdenkulturen da auf
die Achterbahn lassen natürlich ne Leute
aus Bayern oder aus dem Hundsrück na klar
ne ich höre ja gar keine Akzente mehr ja ja
nee so wie es aussieht aber können sich 21%
der Menschen in Deutschland schon schon
vorstellen die mal wieder probeweise zu
benutzen die Achterbahn ne ja und da haben wir
gedacht D machen wir die wieder auf ja und da
haben wir uns aber was besonderes einfallen
lassen da haben wir jetzt vorm Looping haben
wir so ein Fotoapparat ja da bitte einmal in
die Kamera heilhöcke sagen ne würden wir uns
freuen nee ist ja jetzt sind jetzt gerade
viele Parteien sind jetzt in in Aufruhr
natürlich ne CDU SPD fragen sich auch
krass wie können wir den wie können wir da
irgendwie die Wählerinnen und Wähler wieder zu
uns locken ja so AFD ist so hoch ja und dann
sagen viele ja da müssen wir die AFD stoppen durch
Nachahmung nur so ein bisschen nur ein bisschen ja
nur ein bisschen dass man sagt also jetzt nicht
Ausländer raus aber Asyl nur für Inländer so dass
man dass man da langsam reinkommmen ne also dass
das dass man sagt ja also wir wollen die Rechten
stoppen durch immer mehr Einschränkung beim
Asylrecht ja also rechte Position um die Rechten
zu schwächen ne und das funktioniert ja das
muss man immer nur weiter probieren ne ne also
also Rechtspopulisten haben ein Aufwind und dann
übernehmen das andere Parteien ne und dann habe
ich mir gedacht das wäre mal interessant wenn das
bei so einer linksradikalen Partei so wäre ne also
stellen wir uns mal vor so eine linksradikale
Partei hat gerade so Aufwind ja die ist super
populistisch die sagt z.B alle mercedese sollten
brennen ja und das kommt super gut an in der
brennen immer mehr mercedese Felix lobch
zieht oben nach Dubai so es ist richtig
so und so und D würde ich mal dann würde
ich denken so dass die CDU das wieder so
macht ja dass S wieder sagt ja klar D müssen
wir die positionition übernehmen ja klar wir
sind ja Autos anzünden das ist natürlich so
ein wildes Abfackeln von Autos kann es nicht
sein klar aber kontrolliert da müssen wir die
ste in der Bevölkerung vor Mercedes in ernst
nehmen das muss man schon sagen also das ist ja
im Erbe von Konrad Adenauer eigentlich angelegt
ne also wer noch nie ein Autospiegel
abgetreten hat der wä für den ersten
[Musik] Stein herzlich Willkommen zu till Reiners
endcard hier kann man es abonnieren hier
gibt es andere Videos die man sich angucken
kann das war's auch schon
wieder bei till Reiners endcard